- [Narrator] This patch of land,
about 70 miles outside of Houston, Texas
doesn't look like much but if you zoom in,
these little rectangles sit
above a powerful economic
and political tool.
Just underground is a network
of caverns full of oil,
part of the US's Strategic
Petroleum Reserve or SPR.
Since March, President Biden
has been tapping into it in a big way.
- The Department of Energy released
another 15 million barrels
from the Strategy Petroleum Reserve.
- [Narrator] All together,
the administration
will have released 180
million barrels in 2022,
the largest drawdown from the SPR ever.
Pumping from the reserve,
the administration says
has helped lower Americans' energy bills,
and stabilize markets.
But some oil industry experts disagree.
- When we talk about the forces
that are hitting the oil market,
this does very little to change the tide.
- [Narrator] Here's how the
Strategic Petroleum Reserve
can be used to try to bring down prices,
and why some are skeptical
that Biden's moves are working.
(pensive music)
Along the Texas and Louisiana coasts,
the caverns are located in Bryan Mound,
Big Hill, West Hackberry,
and Bayou Choctaw.
As of October 28th,
the reserve held about 399
million barrels of oil.
- We're talking about sort
of four storage sites, 60 caverns.
The largest one I think is big enough
that you could fit the Willis Tower
that you have in Chicago in it.
And the tower four for
reference is 1,451 feet.
That's substantial.
You could put a lot of oil in there.
- [Narrator] So why does
the US government keep
this much oil on hand?
It goes back to the Energy Policy
and Conservation Act of 1975.
During the 1973 to '74 OPEC oil embargo,
prices for oil skyrocketed.
- As a result, we face the possibility
of temporary fuel shortages
and some increases in
fuel prices in America.
- [Narrator] This led
to gasoline shortages
across the country.
- No gas.
- There's no gas today?
- No.
- [Narrator] When President
Ford signed the act into law,
it was an attempt to establish a buffer
against future supply shocks of this kind.
It specified that presidents
can tap into the reserves
when there's an energy supply interruption
or due to obligations of the United States
under the international energy program.
Over the years, that's meant a few things.
- Historically, the US
has drawn to the SPR
for emergency and non-emergency releases.
What's an emergency release?
It's a hurricane that
disrupts all production.
And what's a non-emergency drawdown?
It's a sale mandated by Congress as part
of policy making.
- [Narrator] Using that authority,
Biden tapped into the reserves
starting in the spring
and through this fall.
- We 're gonna continue
to stabilize markets
and decrease the prices at a time
when the actions of other countries
have caused such volatility.
- The market for oil has been very tight.
And the US has had to balance
the fight against inflation,
and gasoline prices has
been a main driver of that
with targeting Russia and punishing it
for its invasion of Ukraine.
- [Narrator] Releases from the
SPR can help calm oil traders
by injecting more crude
supplies into global markets.
Right now, oil supplies are
tight, causing high prices.
By taking oil from the reserves
and selling it to traders and refiners,
Biden is increasing supply
in an effort to lower prices at the pump
because gasoline prices
are largely determined by oil prices.
This strategy has worked in the past.
Take when the government
tapped into the reserve
after Hurricane Katrina as an example.
The US sold 11 million barrels
to keep production study
for the rest of the country.
After the release, prices stabilized.
And something similar
happened earlier this year due
to Biden's March announcement
when he said he'd release
one million barrels a day.
- Treasury Department estimates
that the releases that
we've seen this year,
lower the price of gasoline
between 13 and 31 cents per gallon.
So that's a pretty broad range.
- [Narrator] But industry
critics say that the oil releases
have artificially lowered
prices in the short term,
dissuading investment
in new oil production.
US officials said they had
intended the reserve releases
to be a stop gap until
domestic production ramped up.
- There's only be a slight
increase in production
so far this year, about 6% since January.
And that's largely because
the large producers in the US
have been conservative about spending.
- [Narrator] Biden has tried
to deal with lower production
by announcing that he
would refill the reserve.
- That means all companies can invest
to ramp up production now
with confidence they'll
be able to sell their oil
to us at that price in the future, $70.
- [Narrator] But analysts have said
that shifting from releasing the reserves
to refilling them could
remove large amounts of oil
from the global market,
which would continue to tighten supplies
and contribute to inflation.
They say that Biden should
wait to refill the reserves
until there's a surplus
of oil and lower prices.
The latest release from the reserve,
the 15 million barrels,
are said to be delivered in December.
- Biden has said that
he would ask his team
at the Department of Energy
to, depending on the situation,
make further releases from the SPR.
So he has not ruled out
additional releases.
- [Narrator] Until the SPR is refilled,
federal inventories are at a 38-year low
but Biden says there is still
enough in case of emergency.
(dramatic music)